il existe aujourd'hui une formule
centrale le maquereau nisme qui exercent
une évidente hégémonie sur l'ensemble de
la vie politique
la conséquence directe nécessaire et la
valorisation de son contraire
[Musique]
les français ont le sentiment de vivre
ces derniers temps une situation de
crise sociale mais pour beaucoup
également éprouve de forte frustration
politique
je crois que cela tient à la
modification de notre système politique
qui était jusqu'à présent a régi par une
alternance presque systématique depuis
1981 à ce schéma d'alternance
systématique et finalement assez apaisés
a succédé un changement des codes et le
remplacement partiel ou qui la joue
droite par un clivage qui lui est
perpendiculaire qui est parfois défini
par l'opposition entre les progressistes
et les populistes ce titre bloc contre
bloc renvoie à la notion de bloc
élitaire d'un côté de bloc populaire de
l'autre
donc d'un côté le bloc à lithaire celui
dont l'expression politique a été en
2010 est la candidature d'emmanuel
macron et un bloc populaire qui se
cherche qui n'a pas véritablement lui de
atteint son degré de maturité
[Musique]
l'élément déclencheur pour l'écriture de
ce livre c'est une démarche tout de même
un peu dit gentin c'est pas quelque
chose dans lequel on se lance
naturellement ça a été très clairement
le phénomène des gilet jaune
[Musique]
c'est le vigile brumaire de louis
bonaparte écrit par le quart marc bloch
un marx historiens le karl marx
sociologue pas le militant est la
période avec laquelle je fais des
comparaisons pour voir davantage les
contrastes que les ressemblances c'est
la période
1848 1851 c'est à dire la deuxième
république
[Musique]
il me semble que le clivage qui
prédomine c'est justement un clivage qui
n'est pas celui des élites contre le
peuple c'est totalement caricatural et
ça n'explique pas grand chose ce n'est
pas la france d'en haut
contre la france d'en bas ça aussi
signer savent est apparu un peu trop
sommaire mais disons qu'avec cette
tentative pour décrire ces blocs
il me semblait que je touchais à un
élément véritablement un structurants et
explicatif des dynamiques en cours
[Musique]